[Music]
in Mo Money mo charity news o submitted
by sugar sugar McKenzie Bezos explains
why she's given away most of her money
from the divorce I saw a picture of
McKenzie besos she brought that
bad-looking dude for billionaire that's
pretty hot it's pretty hot for a
billionaire yeah I saw a picture of
Mosley yo she actually got slightly cute
dude because most brilliant that I saw a
photo but I was like she kind of cute
she's giving away 35 bills she became
like insanely rich after their do I bet
I never heard of if I was Jeff I would
probably try to do everything in my
[ __ ] power to keep that marriage
together I'm like you want to bring it
another man let's do it let's just say
to guess how much of a [ __ ] she is
though 35 billion
oh yeah cuz he cheated on her
with that extra oh so you didn't even
have a choice this is a good picture of
them though she I have there's another
angle of the same of that they both
still look busted that's a good picture
but you know the same evaluate there's
another I'm just like oh [ __ ] yeah would
you rather be busted and rich or like
busted and rich busted and rich
it's beautiful import busted and rich
yeah yeah if you know how to work at
natural beauties yeah there's a lot work
right now I'm busted and bored I think
so busted and rich right now I did the
most beautiful girl in the world
remember the little the little girl she
was from Philippines I think oh you mean
with the eyes yeah that's Afghanistan Oh
Afghanistan Oh with the natural
Geographic yeah she ain't grow up to be
that fine though
oh really I haven't seen her baby to
open it here we did yeah he's like she
didn't grow up to be that fine she's
busted in her prime at like nine years
old you know to mean the one we talked
about was the French girl the little
white girl she's the one that grew up
and she's still modeling and she's not
as beautiful anyway so let's check here
Mackenzie bezels she is standing as a
fourth richest woman in the world after
her divorce settlement
so her net worth is about 36 billion
who's number one Oprah [ __ ] Harry
Potter lady dude I don't know how that
would feel like I'm not into someone
else's money that made it no I don't
even care
she was involved in a company so she
just wasn't arm candy well she was an
arm candy in general but like you just
call a salt water taffy did she sleep
finest [ __ ] when you're her age right
hey I don't have four billion dollars so
shoot the true winner 31 35 billion
billion oh my god how did I get four
billion okay give away 35 she helped
build the company and she was involved
and so yeah she was it's not a give away
half of it to a non-profit she owns I
bet to charity no so she is among the 19
billionaires that have signed The Giving
Pledge which oh the Bill Gates think
it's a group founded by Bill Gates and
Warren Buffett Bill vengers is the room
that smells like tiger balm and I see ha
and with squeaky [ __ ] shoes everybody
wears Crocs yeah you know those [ __ ]
Nikes that like I don't know how they
like the rubber gets shiny and they just
squeak your dad yeah yes so this group
is founded by Bill Gates and Warren
Buffett in 2010 and then asked the
world's wealthiest people to commit to
donating the bulk of their money to
charity and so she she signed this
pledge and she said this I have no doubt
that tremendous value comes when people
act quickly on the impulse to give no
Drive has more positive ripple effects
than the desire to be of service we each
come by the gifts we have to offer by an
infinite series of influences and lucky
breaks we can never fully understand in
addition to whatever assets life has
nurtured in me I have the disparate I
have a disproportionate amount of money
to share [ __ ] yeah billions if
philanthropy will continue to be
thoughtful it will take time and effort
and care but I won't wait and I will
keep it at it until the safe is empty so
this was like a kind of like big [ __ ]
you subtweet to her ex-husband because
for a while he said that he so in 2018
he pledged to give two billion dollars
like he waited to help homeless families
and create a network of preschools for
children and low-income areas but he's
done it so well he's notorious for being
super [ __ ] cheap ESDA toys or not
giving away to anything 35 billion I
could give away its high weight 30 4.5
billion and I'd be okay yeah you're
never gonna be able to use that much
money in your lifetime wait all that and
I would still be ridiculously rich and I
could still give the charity with the
money left over I love that big [ __ ] you
to him though yeah yeah so the women
that are more rich than shoes yeah so
number one is at fifty four billion
dollars which is a L'Oreal heiress mmm
forty four billion is held by Alice
Walton and 37 billion is held by
Jacqueline Badger Mars [ __ ] these people
Mars bar Mars bars and I don't know okay
boy oh the Walton family the Walmart
hey what if you held the title for
number one richest man in the world but
number two richest man was only a
billion below you would you still give
away that many billions I don't give a
[ __ ] but that's why I'm not a rich
person it depends you can to be able to
say no richest man in the world yeah it
depends if you care about the title so
she's 36 the Mars lady is 37 so 1
billion is a [ __ ] but all those people
are heirs oh yeah all eras she's she's a
she's a top self-made female billionaire
yeah oh yeah oh yeah weird oh yeah yeah
that's how ballin the Walmart family is
yeah Sam Walton alone he [ __ ] made so
much money that after his death it went
down to like I think it's five children
and all five of them are on the top 100
list of richest people in the world
still that crazy
are there any billionaire lesbians she's
a billionaire out of the billionaires of
the world so there are two that one more
lesbian
there are 2208 billionaires in the world
right
there's only 256 of them that are women
wait wait wait mm what 2208 yeah only
256 10% we may got to work harder doing
what the hell for 10 percent are women
women but how many are lesbian as the
real boys because I want to see two
girls fight getting a divorce and figure
out how they settle that [ __ ] who
becomes the richer who breaks it breaks
off like why why can't it be to you guys
that's not as fun there's more guys that
are billionaire I don't get what you're
trying to get at who gets more money
what's fun out of the alimony er okay
but it has to be specifically to females
not to men cuz ok so right now
cheeseball a night and it's cool to see
all these women coming up
I've already seen dudes fight wars I've
seen plenty of gay dudes slapbox and
West Hollywood I'm tired of combat
sports with dudes so you want to see how
two women go through a divorcee some
huge
yeah I don't want to see like reruns of
the past yeah that's what two guys
fighting is boring yeah with two gay
guys who are married fight each other
that's not even domestic violence it's
just two guys fighting that is the
message violence no it's not all the
women that's just to die selling [ __ ]
down the south it is so the number one
most richest woman she's number eleven
out of all of the billionaires Wow
that's pretty high up there and and who
is it is it a hair a millionaire yeah
she's an air like Solorio l'oreal lady
she's 65 years old
I thought Oprah was [ __ ] up there or
maybe because she's the first black
female billionaire or something like
that when I got you dude it's crazy
because she's not even on that list but
she's like bought property on Maui
that's like a hundred million dollars
worth or like some she's gonna be just
fine so the disparity of wealth is crazy
even if you just had one billion that's
insane you said 1 million that's nice
you could buy a rocket ship yeah - okay
so 2,200 billionaires yeah 2208 on top
of that then we have the hundred
millionaires so we have billionaires and
we have the 100 millionaires like if you
make 999 million you're not a
billionaire but you're still hella rich
yeah cuz at a certain point you Stritch
to me like it doesn't matter to me at
them yeah yeah cuz 300 million is still
a ton of money that's enough to be on
Shark Tank yeah my brain can't really
compute anything after by the way don't
talk to him he's a he's a [ __ ] twenty
million air and but I'm a like a five
hundred millionaire same [ __ ] to me it
doesn't matter is that your white shoe
they knew you had less white shoes you
know not even human Mackenzie's number
22 yeah that's me and Z who's Mackenzie
lady we're talking about Mackenzie bezel
oh I'll just adjust bezels wife she's
the saltwater I got she has no identity
of her own crazy looks good friend tear
designer I guess yeah look at a picture
she's a species hot dude I think you're
so self man single survey says the
ladies what no I mean how did you find
out all the ladies were inherited each
person's name and scroll down in show
but I ran out of my free articles for
Bloomberg so I can't tell you more
information
she's so I wonder out of those like to
2,000 billionaires how many of them are
self-made and how many of them are yeah
okay it is so it's so crazy to start
from wherever you're at and gonna say is
considered crime general I wouldn't it
so Hugh I didn't she having a go fund me
for it I would even consider wasn't
there like a go fund me or something for
either Kendall or Kylie to make her the
first self-made oh billionaire yeah it
was like for the fans yeah the the
technical term for self-made is if
you're a first generation and you made
it through your business or whatever
connections this is like your parents
were solid
isn't self me she is self-made no I know
like I'm saying like she's at Hilton
area like that we would accept as a self
me that she would classify your your in
okay so you're self-made if you didn't
inherit wealth so like so for example
like if your parents died or whatever
right and then like though like the
walton family right like Sam Walton he
made the billions and then the second
generation gets inheritance then then
you're not self-made in Paris's case her
paralyzed she had connections all that
she is self-made I get the technical
thing but I'm like nah well yeah cuz the
word self-made you think they did it all
by themselves you think i rags to riches
brother
if someone in this room without billions
yeah it's like that's [ __ ] itself me
yeah like Mark Zuckerberg Greg he's
self-made yes yeah or or Jeff Bezos he's
self-made right but there is a gray area
like steve aoki and all that stuff yes
he had a rich dad or whatever but they
didn't get any of that money
Mark Zuckerberg didn't come from any
money at all cuz he went to Harvard yeah
but they're not billionaires or they're
not billionaires the like I'm saying
like more than rags to riches well
that's just like I said that's just a
personal thing but boy I hear the rags
to riches story because you want to
relate to a tional yeah for example like
what the one the Jenner girl she's
[ __ ] kajillion heir right and she got
a lot of flack because people say she
doesn't count because her parents are
rich but at the same time she still
created her own empire on her own thing
yeah so I do understand because she
definitely had a leg up yeah sure she
had a huge leg up she had all these
connections she grew up in a house of
wealth yeah at the same time is she
didn't inherit the millions of dollars
she's the billionaire mark is incredible
yes she added like two more zeros to
whatever should start up with so that's
pretty crazy
I think the top three people are
self-made Jeff bezels
I think it's know if Carlos Slim is
still up there Bill Gates Carlos Slim
he's the Mexican Oh I mean occations guy
yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]